bonsoir emmanuelli merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france ce
passeport le gouvernement espagnol en
rêve manifestement et vous en tant que
médecin eh bien écoutez du rêve à la
réalité il ya toujours une distance et
c'est vrai quand on n'arrive pas bien
savoir à imaginer ce que seront les
contours de ce fameux passeport
vaccinale parce qu'on s'est d'une part
que les et les touristes vacciner
pourront quand même effectivement
transporté le virus et d'autre part
effectivement on voit mal un passeport
vaccinale s'affranchir des tests pcr
pour l'épauler pour les futurs voyageurs
donc c'est vrai que bon entre le rêve
effectivement d'un passeport universel
qui permettrait effectivement de revenir
à la normalité et la réalité des
problèmes techniques qui vont se poser
pour ce passeport est bien il ya quand
même une différence c'est un va te
téléphone
alors vous le disais on ne connaît pas
encore son contenu effectivement
pcr vous l'avez dit carnet de
vaccination il ya des divisions au sein
du gouvernement vous pour vous quelle
serait la meilleure solution
écoutez pour moi je pense qu' il n'y a
pas de solution idéale
nous sommes en chemin vers la
vaccination massive de la population et
on sait que quand on aura atteint un
certain pourcentage de la population
vaccinée on peut espérer effectivement
effectué en une espèce de débiner micky
qui s'étendrait et qui permettrait de
revenir peut-être la normalité avec des
décontaminations sporadiques mais quand
à trouver une solution administrative un
problème effectivement épidémiologique
je pense que la route est encore longue
alors non france on a vu il ya certains
responsables gouvernementaux qui ont
lancé l'idée ça a été évidemment repris
avec pas mal de critiques sur le thème
des libertés individuelles pas ce type
de débat en espagne
comment accueillir et la population
cette initiative
ici nous sommes à quelques semaines
maintenant de la semaine à santa qui est
un petit peu là le lancement de la
saison printanière et estivale et donc
ici tous les tous les regards et toutes
les attentions sont dirigés vers
l'ouverture cette nouvelle saison est
donc le temps n'est pas à la polémique
mais à l'espoir et tout le monde ici
espère pouvoir retrouver une saison à
peu près normale enfin cette année alors
cela passera on le dit dans tous les
pays par la vaccination comment se passe
la vaccination justement vous en tant
que médecin est ce qu'au sein de votre
cabinet vous vacciner des espagnols
toute la journée
alors moi je ne vaccinent pas parce que
le vaccin pour des raisons de logistique
en fait et distribué uniquement dans les
centres de santé publics et cette
vaccination
effectivement il se passe très bien
puisque sur 5 2 5 millions vaccin qu'a
reçues à ce jour l'espagne et bien elle
en administrer 5 millions c'est dire si
effectivement le circuit logistique
fonctionne bien et c'est vrai que
personne ne se plaint ici du déroulement
de la vaccination
personne sauf peut-être justement les
expatriés car tous ceux effectivement
qui ne sont pas inscrits au niveau du
système public espagnol n'ont pas accès
aujourd'hui au vaccin ce qui correspond
quand même un nombre important
d'expatriés français
alors justement en france on se plaint
les médecins comme vous se plaignent à
un grosse colère des médecins olivier
verront leur a d'ailleurs répondu hier
soir parce qu'ils ont finalement
transféré les vaccins aux pharmaciens
pour qu'ils puissent vacciner à partir
du 15 mars pour vous c'est clair la
situation pas de pharmaciens pas de
médecins uniquement des gros centres de
vaccination ici c'est pas vraiment des
gros centres peut dire qu'ils utilisent
le système de chanter tel qu'il existe
et c'est vrai que le système espagnol
est un système très administrée donc ce
système là j'allais dire est assez idéal
pour les campagnes de prévention de
masse pour les campagnes de vaccination
de masse c'est un système qui fait ses
preuves dans ce type de situation mais a
contrario tout n'est pas rose c'est à
dire que ces systèmes qui met en oeuvre
cette vaccination avec effectivement des
beats au effectuant de vaccination très
satisfaisant et bien par ailleurs sont
saturés pour ce qui concerne la médecine
générale de tous les jours pour les
soins de tous les jours et c'est vrai
qu'on entend effectivement un certain
nombre de patients se plaint de ne plus
pouvoir accéder au centre pour des
pathologies habituelles alors oliveira
exprimé ce soir enfants son inquiétude
quant aux variantes plus contagieux plus
dangereux en français 65% des cas qu'en
est-il en espagne vous partager la même
crainte ici on espère y en a de très
bons chiffres c'est-à-dire qu'on arrive
à une incidence qui est de l'ordre de
voiliers 133 1000 cas pour 100000
habitants ce qui est ce qui est ce qui
est vraiment très
raisonnable puisque l'objectif avoué
épidémiologiquement et de revenir vers
environ une incidence de 50 pour cent
mille habitants
donc on sent bien qu'on en est pas loin
et tout cela avec des mesures qui
auraient été beaucoup plus souple qu'en
france donc les résultats sur le terrain
sont vraiment bons pour autant le
variant anglais neuneu n'a pas encore je
dirais la même importance qu en france
et donc il se pourrait qu'on ait des
surprises dans dans le mois qui vient
ses surprises été annoncée pour la fin
du mois de mars
donc peut-être que la situation peut
évoluer dans les quelques semaines qui
viennent faire à suivre donc merci
philippe emmanuel in nous avoir fait
part de cette situation en espagne merci
à vous